the yipao parade was born more than
25 years ago
what was sought was how to reflect
our identity, our idiosyncrasies
and what we
peasants do for a living my family does it for the
guy's parade he does it out of passion it's
something very wasteful and if it hadn't
passion we would not be here
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is adriana patricia durán for
more than 20 years my families have been
participating in the
yipao parade contest the yipao parade is a
cultural event
where recognition of the  hit that is the one that
has led to development in our
region
[Music]
initially the economy and
transportation was done on the back of a mule because
there were no roads because of its state
so we adopted the gym
[Music]
so
my family coffee shop as our occupation department  we think
it is good to reflect in a jeep even what
is the coffee culture so my car
is decorated with everything that is used
in the farm  It takes around two days to get to the coffee maker to
process a coffee bean.
Organizing and assembling
the vehicle is assembled little by little
and each little thing is tied up
carefully because each little thing tells
a story.
The parade of the yipao breaks apart in
several categories and we participate in
several categories there is the category of
agricultural cargo my husband also competes
in that
arts and crafts category also because we use
that it is my category
the yipao contest the prize is
money and he won
first place for the gym almost every year  number one
adriana here
[Music]
[Applause]
apart from being a cultural manifestation it
is something familiar behind the street there is a
family and behind each family there is a
story
[Music]
so the contestants each year are almost
always the same but as
new ones come  generations behind
us grows more because it is like the
legacy we leave in each of
our loved ones
[Music]
[Applause]